salut tout le monde
épisode 34 de la saison 3 d'envergure
une saison qui dure qui dure c'est une
saison à rallonge et évidemment et on
est avec un français candidat à la draft
aujourd'hui draft qui se tiendra en le
rappel en octobre mais ça se fait rare
les français candidats à la draft
puisque ces derniers jours et joël à
yayi et france ont décidé de retourner à
la fac pour une année supplémentaire on
est donc avec tidiane tilly ils gagnent
merci d'être avec nous très cool merci à
vous merci à vous en direct de spokane
ou bien dans le nord-ouest américain
pour situer un petit peu c'est là où tu
étais à la fac c'est là où se trouve la
la saq de gonzaga
ouais c'est sage toujours aux états unis
tout l'été un peu un peu bloqué ici
malgré moi mais moi je sais ça on va
justement parlé de ça ça tombe bien on
va parler de ce processus pré draft
jamais vu en fait parce que à distance à
rallonge etc
on va savoir comment se porte la cote au
niveau des franchises nba donc vous les
voyez également à l'écran normalement
ben romain alan sont là pour poser
question messieurs comment avez-vous
talus al aqsa bien toi parfaitement bien
j'ai tout mis dans le décor d'un gros
budget gros budgets du côté de la gauche
on sait il c'est lui là la banque la
banque d'envergure c'est lui qui a passé
notre big ben et moi on a fait l'effort
du fond blanc quand même c'est joli
c'est joli donc je voulais c'est le
croit le crachoir messieurs pour pour
poser les questions à killian on va
d'abord on va débuter première partie
d'interview sur vraiment les les
interviews justement que même les
franchises nba en ce moment alors
qu'elles ont menées qu'elle continue on
sait pas justement on va te demander qui
viennent et c'est ben qui s'en chargent
vas-y ben je t'en prie bon ben may
killian merci d'être avec nous c'est un
joueur d'ici qu'on apprécie et
deuxièmement je voulais savoir aperçu
avec
l'agent l'équipe lyonnaise du processus
pré draft qui est un petit sort du tarn
et août voilà ton processus présentement
est ce que tu as parlé à toutes les
équipes déjà comment est ce que tu es un
forme comment est ce que ma carte de
nous expliquer ça ouais donc pas fait
les interviews ont commencé il ya
longtemps j'étais genre à peu près genre
de trois semaines après la saison j'ai
quasiment fait toutes les équipes déjà
en mai juin
même s'il ya des équipes qui prennent
leur temps de leslie préparation à part
sur leur emploi du temps donc on a
beaucoup tard ça et ça se passe bien il
pourrait coûter sont vraiment personnel
pas ce qu'ils savent déjà comment tu
joue donc et voyez s'il s'est posé des
questions en pierre un peu des fois donc
ça comme ça
et sinon physiquement et pour howard 4 a
pas de voir 4 devant les équipes
il faut juste jeune âge du butin enfin
physiquement je travaille toujours à
gonzague à l essai de dagg j'attends
c'est d'être patient d'attendre
est-ce que les skate fait tellement de
fois fallait voir carte via zune ou
skype encore je pense pas qu'ils ont
conversa pour l'instant que lol mais
j'espère qu'on peut faire de desmaures
calmer un truc quoi il ya eu des rumeurs
dans bas j'ai reçu l'invitation mais mes
stands at 100/100 lieu donc on va juste
une façon sans rien c'est une
c'est une idée plus une réalité jusqu'à
maintenant voilà
bon d'accord mais se parlait de parler
de questions pièges pensée auquel quel
genre de questions des questions sur
leur équipe
si tu as bien révisé sur leur équipe
quel joueur je t'aime les regarder le
style de jeu que dans le fond ce
compagnie veut savoir si je comprends
bien quel genre de joueur que je suis
voilà voilà c'est ça moisi que presque
toutes les équipes avaient avait
contacté ce que tu sais les sites apple
ical ne l'ont pas faire un homme
six équipes qu'ils ont pas commencé leur
process de prévoir que l'on fonce et
lakers ont pas encore fait vous voyez
comme ça mais la mêlée ouais ce qui m'a
ils ont la nbi et maintenant je suis
allé avec l équipe du direct lui le
meilleur contact dans lesquels quelques
sélections du ressenti j'ai pas vraiment
une équipe aura mais tous les tous
autant qu'ils sont bien passées et et
j'étais très bon très bon une au
feedback sur les zapa
j'attends de voir ont confiance en moi
quoi ouais je peux par contre j'ai je
parlais avec un scalp indépendant
américain puis il parlait de tes stats
beaucoup dont l'efficacité en tant que
joueur est-ce que ça est ce que ça te s
que le sud est et jean qui est celui des
équipes qui ont fait des promesses de
l'équipe qui ont vraiment le fait que ce
soit un joueur fier à face à face très
versatile et très efficace est ce que tu
lui les équipes se sont commis un peu
plus non tu faisais pas je pense pas que
des équipes font des promesses
sitôt or et surtout avant qui vont au
dossier médical et tout ça et je pense
que faveur atteindre d'allaitement les
équipes pour pour avoir des premiers
secours donc pour l'instant toujours pas
ok peut-être peut-être une dernière sur
le processus est ce que tu as des
sesquiers quittons compte accepté de
nommer nonce tu veux pas nommer non je
te des équipes qui sont en contact est
plus qu'une fois oui oui oui il compte à
mon argent beaucoup et par ménage en
panne tout avec les skis et ouais on
même peut-être on va voir des interviews
avec les mêmes équipes
un deuxième interview pour pour juste
répondre à d'autres questions
6on de s'imposer connu que moi j'attends
ça est ce que toi tu as refusé de
l'interviewer avec quelques franchises
non non non parce que je suis intéressé
par tous les équipages ont fait ce pas
est-ce que tu as passé des tests de qi
hommes
jan balik horaires et l'agent de ces
quelques équipes le font je sais que
l'orlando comme ses choix ouais ouais
j'avais encore de la semaine prochaine
et a même dédié à même une équipe qui
m'ont envoyé un appel pour que ce pas de
crise et après je leur renvoie l'ipad
c'est marrant mais des fois après
l'interview kouilou surtout sur la
personnalité vous tue le désinfecte
avant l'ipad
comment ça se passe justement tu parlais
tonton dossier médical c'est un gros
point d'interrogation pour beaucoup de
franchise même pour toi un petit peu
mais ça ne donnerait enfin pas ton
dossier m sur ce qui peut arriver on va
prendre des nouvelles de ce côté là
c'est romain qui va s'en charger on va
parler de ta préparation tu parles est
ta préparation physique
bazire au moins dans ce que tu peux nous
dire maintenant et non sur le truc sur
lequel je peux communiquer à l'heure
actuelle parce que j'imagine qu'il ya
certains trucs bons qui sont peut-être
un peu que tu gardes pour toi pour les
discussions qui est franchie temps et où
à l'heure actuelle physiquement et
comment est-ce que tu as tu travaillé
sur les sur les semaines et les mois qui
ont précédé le temps un peu mort de tous
les désastres
j'ai beaucoup de temps pour récupérer et
gérer des problèmes de suivi genou et
j'ai tapé chance à tous tous les trois
étaient des boutiques de sujets j'ai
beaucoup renforcé et un aimable
maintenant ça va beaucoup mieux et c'est
une bonne chose dans ce collectif
d'avoir autant pour moi ça maintenant je
suis prêt pour pour la draft des pompes
pour mettre en mode synthèse carte
bancaire tu as fais ça tu as fait ça
avec le staff là bas où tu as quelqu'un
qui t'accompagne ouais j'avais beau
geste aranoa gars mais aussi avant avant
que tout est éteint
pour un petit moment j'avais une salle
de commande y de matinée et où je
faisais ma musculature
je faisais de la kiné je faisais tout
mais c'était ouvert pendant que tout
était fermé
donc tu n'as pas ta pas forcément eu de
lure quoi à 1 qu'il est l'extérieur ou
quelque chose comme ça particulièrement
rester vraiment ce que je connaissais ce
que donc là aujourd'hui tard après quoi
tu après un entraînement à peu près
normale dans le contexte où vous êtes où
vous êtes comment la sueur de sur le
coin pour elle tout sens ouais à peu
près normale après est-ce qu'on va donc
adapter à beaucoup de règles mais après
on fait quand même des trucs en dehors
de nos intérêts on fait ce qu'on veut ce
que tout le monde fait quoi et c'est
vraiment normalement même si comme si
les arizona
c'est un truc c'est correct que jude ici
c'est complètement hallucinant je le
confirme
c'est complètement les financer
correctement de choses puis un décalage
complet par rapport à la situation des
gens vivent comme du roman qu'il y aille
j'ai une question on en parle dans tes
interviews pour faire le lien avec
question de ben est question de romans
de 2 de son état de santé de ton passif
médical tentative de blessure
si les équipes de pose de questions
comme ça ouais ouais ils disent vraiment
que non mais quasiment tous deux équipes
sont intéressées il veut juste voir mon
dossier médical avant et des voir si
voix la csu jeu fiable
c'est vraiment c'est ça ou les touts les
équipes on a tous peur pour moi après
moi je suis serein niveau là donc j'ai
pas remplacer sam et les équipements
je prie à leur montrer que je suis
dedans tu leur as envoyer ton âge
comment comment tu as à sept procès de
ils attendent de faire leurs propres
tests avec leur propre médecin ça ou
alors normand combat tout mais tout le
dossier médical pour renvoyer les
équipes
je voudrais que j'ai envie de dire à
combien alors toi tu disais que ça avait
plutôt joué en ta faveur pour récupérer
je le disais en introduction coéquipiers
jouent à la galerie et il pense ont tous
les deux retourner à la fac il ya plein
de joueurs qui sont retournés à la saq
aussi ont décidé de retourner une année
de plus ancien ces derniers jours est ce
que tu peux nous expliquer pourquoi en
gros chacun sa gestion propre mais il ya
quand même une vague générale pourquoi
ton ami à moi je pense déjà que le fait
qu'ils ont supprimé march madness
tout le monde a envie de jouer juste ou
la saison pour pour pour le march
madness est ce que tu fais pas ça c'est
comme si tu avais la saison donc je
pense que les joueurs veulent avoir une
autre chance de se montrer à en mars
parce que c'est vraiment tout le monde
la visibilité en mars et un pas que tous
les jours faire ça je pense c'est pour
ça que la mois de la plupart des gens
reviennent et concernant joël plus
précisément il ya de grandes ambitions à
gonzaga et prochaine ouais on a de très
bonnes recrues qui arrive après c'est
vrai qu'on a perdu à l'épée troussel
mais bon je pense qu'il ya des très bons
joueurs car il a toujours qui sont déjà
là bas pour revenir sur le côté médical
est ce que tu sais pas si tu regarde un
peu les mauves draft ou pas mais si on
met de côté le l'aspect blessures est ce
que tu penses que tu pourrais être au
premier tour de cette draft et alors que
là c'est pas certain
oui vraiment ça m'a stoppé dans ma main
puis stoppée au niveau de la confiance
des équipes pour que vraiment et je
pense que j'avais le niveau pour être un
premier tout juste eu à les blessures le
risque de mort tous un peu plus loin
nous la troisième partie de l'interview
s'avère justement sur ce dont tu parlais
tout à l'heure le rôle dans lequel les
équipes s'imaginer dans lequel toi tu
t'imagines et ce qu'il peut y avoir un
décalage rapport aux questions qu'on se
pose par rapport à ce que toi tu as vécu
et par rapport à ce que la nba est
aujourd'hui un levier qui a repris un
peu de temps alan vasys temps pour que
les questions
moi je voulais savoir parce que tu as
joué avec beaucoup de l'intérieur
j'entends tout repenser à sa rivale
jeter même je vous dire si je me trompe
mais sur certaines séquences de march
madness l'année passée depuis retrouvé
poste 3 sur des t td l'année par un
certain moment moi je veux savourer ce
que tu commentes sens si on te fait
jouer devant la poste 5 en sortie de
banc avec des zodiac autant de travaux
ça va aujourd'hui est ce que tu penses
que défensivement le post 5 tu étais
prêt pour le défendre en nba ouais bah
ouais beaucoup de l'équipement de monza
je pense que ouais je pense que gérard
davantage offensivement je peux chuter
ce brave espère que tout faire un en
attaque et ça existe défense et moi je
l'aï un peu manqué de taille et de poids
c'est contre les apostats et je pense
pas que c'est un gros problème
je peux jouer autour ce que je veux
autour d'eux veut tous les soirs comme
ça et je pense que physiquement mal
c'est plus vos parents vos problèmes moi
je rappelle qu'à 40
% à 3 points en carrière il sied sur un
peu moins de 250 tentative choix donc
shooter de très haute voltige
moi c'est ça qui m'intéresse sur le rôle
offensif voilà les équipes font des
fautes à mettre dans des situations
assez simple sur les situations de
picamoles poux des situations comme je
l'aï dit je peux aussi pas fait donc tu
peux prendre des décisions en sortie de
pick and roll et c'est toi qui pose les
prend pour ensuite y remonte à pas mal
de faire ça comment tu te sens là
parlement pour prendre des décisions
c'est une cause ou tard il a progressé
en termes de ratio de pertes de balle
passe et décide comment tu te sens au
parlement par rapport à il ya quelques
années je me sens moi je me sens bien à
les agacer tout ce que je faisais
quasiment beaucoup de décisions parce
que quand tu viens à entrer leur cause a
gâté ses taux qui décide où je vais
aller une coton j'adore jouer comme ça
et et supprime pour faire ça un billet
et surtout qu'arras a bien plus d'espacé
des mots qu'on joue et que c'était pour
moi le goût le tir
batta des stades qui parle pour toi
comment tu es ce que tu sens que tu peux
encore progresser là dessus et voilà le
pitch and putt une maîtrise vraiment
bien est ce que katia de type de tir que
tu peux apporter à attend jeu sachant
que je pense quand même bien on te
demanderont beaucoup de prendre et de
tirs à trois points en sortie de banc
non je pense que vois je beaucoup baissé
trois points je pense que j'étais déjà
beaucoup plus rapidement je travaille
beaucoup sur ça et ouais c'est vraiment
juste jeter rapidement et plus on être
plus stable et je pense que ça va
m'aider mbigou quel genre de travail
spécifique dans ta préparation des
derniers mois tu as fait pour aller vers
ce rôle qui va être le tient en nba qui
était pas le tiens vraiment une si noble
est vraiment sûr de la travail des pieds
et la stabilité sur 48 tirs 1 et après
juste gardé le même cher monsieur peu
parce que si tu gères tu rapidement
avant je faisais n'importe quoi s'est
blessé avant tout trop tôt ou trop tard
il faut vraiment garder la main mutuelle
juste essayé de la faire rapidement et
au niveau de la défense ce dont parlait
alan tout à l'heure où deux cas de la
capacité à encaisser des vrais postes 5
n oubliez ça ça veut dire quoi au niveau
de la préparation sommes vraiment je
fonce et main une mentalité avant la
vente à vendre autre chose que des
autographes le plus gros plus grande toi
c'est pas un problème juste j'ai
beaucoup je poste de sacs avec nous à
bien des égards énorme et il faut juste
tu mets ton pouce et en plus c'est une
technique que tu peux être un peu moi
moi fort cru mais ça va quand même
marché
hmm hmm je l en but par exemple puissant
que avec le bras tu es solide il est
très confiant la balle aux autres
bref belge derrière mais par jean durand
un joueur comme ça collins ben tu
connais bien il a rejoint peut-il
rejoindre pourtant là et servirait le
deuxième poste 4 parce qu'en fait il ya
des qualités à l'extérieur au tir par
exemple donc c'est possible de les
mettre d'autres ont des alignements avec
un groupe avec un gros qui vaut à la
nourriture présente sensuelle spezi
qu'en fait s'affaisser match racing avec
les intérêts soit si tu shootes en plus
tu dis que tu vas cours d eau chaude ce
qui ferait ce qui fait vraiment peur tu
ne tueras pas le spinning donc ça
pourrait aussi peut-être que tu joues
avec des heures à côté d'un auteur qui
grossit mais ça pourrait être une force
pour toi pour vous pour la draft
pas mal d'intervenants par action avec
alex qui les interdit tirs à trois
points et un niveau là et qui peut un
peu défend de jeu parce que tu en penses
de ces 2,7 nouveau profil là est-ce que
tu arrives pas voilà il ya un bon moment
avec une musicalité voit la france a un
bon moment pour moi
les esquifs chargé des joueurs comme moi
petit peu floutée qui peuvent défunt
était important pour le pressing en
sicile s'est pas jeté mon gars il va
être dans la raquette de lima il va
aider sur tout le monde que c'est
important de ce pc est ce que tu as
travaillé durant situation genre par
exemple sortir en cascade d'écran toi
même prendre une cascade d'écran et
tirer c'est parce qu'on va te demander
probablement dans un premier temps à une
billets mais aujourd'hui on voit des
grands faire ça ouais non mais c'est
vrai que même sur des fils après un pic
à noël où tu dois fils ce que beaucoup
de soutiens comme ça après j'ai pas
vraiment travailler star plein écran
mais a vraiment ouest tout en mouvement
demande a expliqué phil pour ceux qui
sont pas bons c'est pas en france et
plus près français le problème est que
les gens de chez le problème est que les
gens de chute
c'est tout ce qui va être sûr sur un
enchaînement notamment prénuptiale rôle
surtout ce qu'on va être sur les papas
ou sur des choses comme ça c'est ce que
tu veux dire quand il vient compenser à
l'opposé il faut composer des revues
c'est sur le fait de remonter en fait
en français on sait ce que certains
entraîneurs disent tirer derrière le
pick and roll c'est en fait le tout ce
qui va être aspirations liés à la
descente
le fait de remonter justement dernier
les crocs et d'être dans ces espaces où
finalement la défense doit faire un
choix très souvent la défense il doit
rentrer pour protéger la rentrée dans la
dans la peinture
et dans ce cas là c'est là où les quatre
les quatre des quatre modernes sont
capables de remonter ou même devenir
complètement l'opposé dans un jeu où
l'on jouerait vraiment à quatre joueurs
retour avec assurera sur un faux âge où
les joueurs sont capables de revenir de
l'opposer justement de prendre des tirs
dans ces situations là c'est quelque
chose qui de par l'omniprésence du pick
and roll aujourd'hui est devenu très
très importante soit en europe comme en
nba
une belle kylie ann disait sentait le
niveau d'un joueur de premier tour dans
cette draft
est ce que si on excepte les blessures
tu es d'accord qu'on analyse tu m'as
envoyé tombe hors dia pas longtemps je
sais plus combien de cas des classiques
j'avais j'avais 31e mais puisque je
devais avec un avec un dossier médical
mais je sais que lui on parlait depuis
qu'elle demande beaucoup et killian vous
avez tous les sweats je suis avec toute
la polyvalence pour trouve dans les
toiles très agréable à utiliser des deux
côtés du pkra tant que portant le parc
aux élections aux ct pas à ces mêmes
questions
j'aime beaucoup jouer quand j'ai pas la
balle piquée parce qu'ils aiment bien
juste de lire ce que le défenseur fait
mieux quand j'ai dû prendre deux trois
pics avec la balle
non mes quatre années pour sa gamme chez
ses parents travaillent et c'est pour ça
ici
je faisais ça nous aide beaucoup
pourquoi pas mais moi je sais pas par
quoi voter pour moi que j'avais une
question sur le tire peut-être qu'à la
note avec d'autres questions aussi mais
rapidement sur le tir je regardais ddt
chiffres parce que j'étais beaucoup plus
jeune j'ai regardé un peu plus les
chiffres
je trouve que les lettons pourcentage
aux lancers francs correspond pas à
l'adresse générale que tu montes sur le
terrain c'est à dire t'as 75% carrière
c'est bien pour un joueur de talent
c'est plutôt très bon mais c'est pas
excellent nba les joueurs qui jouent
c'est des joueurs excellents est-ce que
tu bosses
ouais t'as un problème pour moi quelque
chose que progresser et comment comment
le travail parce que bon par la
répétition c'est quoi il ya un aspect
mental aussi on en parle régulièrement
pour donner les coordonnées dit à china
huadian touch il faut je place sur place
les amis au passage à appréhender vous
lancer ouais moi c'est mental et aussi
beaucoup de répétitions énormément de
répétition mais juste juste quelque
chose que je travaille beaucoup plus de
sauter dessus voeux à la presse des
questions
pour moi ce shoot c'est le meilleur 21
fautes je te dis pas parce qu'il est là
mais ce point est leur interlocuteur
j'ai un petit groupe avec les intérieurs
shooter entre eux avec jaden smith et
obito pinto way est plutôt oui et
simonovic de monténégrins mais non
franchement façon s'il ya qu à voir sur
sur twitter il doit le voir qu'il ya les
américains qui peut être détruite en
train de lui et son fils de thatta la
chanson fait d'être sur un créneau il
n'y a pas de joueurs comme ça ou très
peu aujourd'hui et l'arrivée des
européens ces dernières années fait de
toute façon son profil correspond à
l'évolution du jeu moderne
si c'est pour ça que ça peut très vite
et on espère ensuite chez moi avec
janick message à certains christian
c'est qu'ils te passe le bonjour au
passage je trouve que les gens profitent
avec ton premier saladier c'était la
rareté est ce que tu penses tu une
armoire comme celle qui est derrière à
la valeur actuelle pourrait faire
l'objet de deux tons premier achat c'est
pas c'est pas à ma grand mère je pense
exactement passé ça c'est celle de mon
arrière grand mère c'est la commode
louis saez avec le premier au provincial
n'diaye bah oui
une stat pour apporter de l'eau au
moulin ce qu'on disait je me suis un peu
amusé mais dans dans les joueurs cette
année en est fier il y en a que deux qui
ont plus de tout loupé je fais le plus
de 90 3 points tentés puisque on
s'arrêtait à 90 n'a pas joué de match à
plus de 35% de réussite et +2 3% 2
contres c'est à dire qu'ils peuvent et
shooter et protéger le cercle il ya toi
et le cas gaza donc à gaza qui s'est
retiré qui retourner à la fac et l'autre
c'est toi donc
donc c'est vrai quand on profite les
rares parmi les joueurs alors il y en a
d'autres mais il faut dans des plus
petites conférences et avec une wave -
moins en moins aux costauds j'avais j'ai
une question je les mange et messieurs
vous avez créé cette question
quels outils que voudrait tomber des
allemands si tu peux choisir tu peux
choisir demain demain tu peux choisir
une bonne le choix aujourd'hui ou demain
c'est pas la france c'est et grandi en
regardant
les spurs et parker mais maurice bien et
c'est une équipe que je regardais jouer
que j'adore le style de jeu prendre je
veux dire ça mais après c'est
franchement un juge le juste une équipe
qui tu veux qu'ils nous faire tu as fait
qu'ils vont faire progresser et qui vous
servent eux quoi ta interviewé avec les
spurs et celle 6 et 7 6
moi j'ai fait lestement wave new york
les équipes alors ces six là c'est nos
équipes c'est pour ça pour l'heure aux
équipes en te remercie beaucoup qui
viennent d'avoir d'avoir pris le temps
de d'être avec nous aujourd'hui pour
pour ce podcast et cette interview
rapide la finir mais c'est vrai que
c'est long de cette période pour toi en
plus ça doit être un peu délicat parce
que si tu chopes le virus tout de suite
c'est un peu encore plus compliqué voilà
le sol français ici c'est joli à voir
des fois je veux le voir donc voilà
c'est tout il va bien joël tout va bien
pour lui ouais super peur il est content
d'avoir faire là précisément là et il
est prêt pour tout à fait la saison
prochaine ça aide le le gabon a l'air
tout à fait sûr sur les lignes arrières
avec une grosse équipe avec johnsons et
la bâtisse choeur entonne watson qui
revient avec oumar ballo à l'intérieur
beaucoup de beaucoup beaucoup d'armes
mais au regard des volumes en toi tu vas
continuer à les suivre
très certainement du côté de woking
merci encore qu'ils gagnent merci
messieurs aussi pour pour les questions
pour lutter dumas sait qu'il ya merci
beaucoup
et puis pour jeux d'envergure on revient
bientôt avec un petit ajustement sur les
joueurs qui ont décidé de revenir à la
fac ou au contraire de se déclarer à la
draft deadline était le 3 août donc donc
on va vous analyser tout ça vous parler
des conséquences sur cette draft est
sûre du coup la drave 2021 ou alors
beaucoup beaucoup de candidats ça où
tout le monde
plus tard